what we've seen over the past seven
months at the Muller investigation
reveals a lot about how big government
can end up becoming a threat to
representative democracy and the more we
look at the web of Clinton and Obama
loyalists who burrowed into Muller's
office the more obvious it all becomes
there were a number of highly
influential and powerful people working
inside the Obama administration who were
not only horrified about the idea of
Donald Trump winning the presidency they
were intent on preventing him from being
elected by any means necessary and if
that meant applying for a FISA warrant
based on a phony dossier in order to spy
on the campaign maybe they'd do it
and if it meant deploying the entire
mainstream media apparatus into DEFCON 1
mode hyperventilating about Russia
collusion 24/7 they'd do it and today if
it requires floating a specious story
alleging that the president has early
onset dementia well they'll do that too
or maybe
spreading damaging falsehoods from
innominate anonymous sources that are
later parroted and then retracted by
major news organizations yeah they'll do
that too and if it means propagating the
idea that Don Trump jr. Jared and the
president were in some conspiracy with
the old KGB to throw the election no
problem whatever it takes
as a former Muller investigator Peter
struck put it they needed an insurance
policy to stop Trump going on to
reference a meeting in Andy's office and
why is that significant well here's the
chairman of the House Judiciary
Committee Bob Goodlatte Andy is
presumably Andrew McCabe the Deputy
Director of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation this text is very
troubling because it suggests that
they're doing something they have a plan
to take action to make sure that Donald
Trump does not get elected president
States in the highest levels of the
Federal Bureau of Investigation now this
entire investigation these texts all of
it
this has become a complete farce they
have an unlimited budget they have an
unlimited staff they have basically an
unlimited term Muller's team can stay on
the hunt forever how long they want it's
insane
the founders never envisioned that a
separate office inside the executive
branch could hire a bunch of
agenda-driven investigators in search of
a crime by the head of the executive
branch
I mean if Congress wants to get rid of
the president they have a way to do that
it's called impeachment that's their
constitutional prerogative but this deal
with Muller is now just totally out of
hand and at a minimum a few things need
to happen immediately in order to at
least stabilize the situation first
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe must
be fired
period he allowed struck to be the lead
investigator of the Russian
investigation after he had been a key
player in the ultimate exoneration of
the Hillary Clinton email investigation
and remember he helped call me soften
the language of his non-indictment
indictment of mrs. Clinton and there's a
lot of other things about struck we
won't go into now but you know I'll know
them by now and whether McCabe actually
conspired with struck and went to the
FISA Court to surveil the Trump campaign
campaign that's really important too and
that also has to be investigated but a
separate grounds for firing McCabe for
cause maybe the meeting struck
references in his text messages the
thing that we just referenced because if
true McCabe actually took part in a
discussion or actual planning who knows
to subvert Trump's campaign or maybe if
he was elected his ability to lead the
government as president of the United
States that text message could be the
smoking gun and as for Bob Mulder
himself indeed he has throughout his
career served his country with honor and
distinction but that doesn't change the
fact that right now this investigation
he's heading has become irreparably
tainted as The Wall Street Journal just
put it the man who should be most
disturbed by all this as mr. Muller
who wants his evidence and conclusions
to be credible with the public evidence
is building instead that some officials
at the FBI who've worked for him may
have interfered in an American
presidential election Congress needs to
insist that its rights as a co-equal
branch of government to exist to
discover the truth now I'm not calling
from other Muller to be fired it's
tempting but I'm not but at the very
least he needs to put the brakes on this
investigation at least pause it for a
bit I agree with what Alan Dershowitz
said on my radio show this morning it's
time for a respected independent expert
to come in and thoroughly examine the
individuals conducting this probe in
fire anyone inside who evinces even a
hint of an appearance of a conflict of
interest that's all it should take
that's how high the stakes are otherwise
the public confidence in the mother
operation will and should collapse under
its own weight these endless revelations
of bias and that's the angle